We begin with that deadly heat across the U.S. and Europe.
Northwestern parts of Europe are seeing some relief today...
...as the high temperatures shift east.
Much of the Iberian peninsula, including Italy, Germany, Austria, even Sweden,...
...are dealing with oppressively hot weather again today.
Record high temperatures in the UK Tuesday...
...caused train tracks to bend and roads to buckle.
Rare wildfires broke out in and around London.
The city logged its hottest day since records began.
The hot weather is fueling out of control wildfires...
...in other parts of Europe as well.
Thousands of people evacuated homes in several countries.
The heat has killed at least seventeen-hundred people in Spain and Portugal alone.
CBS News foreign correspondent Elaine Cobbe joins us from Paris with more on this.
Hi, Elaine. So the extreme heat is causing a lot of damage around Europe,...
...whether it be to infrastructure, wildfires, or most upsettingly, the human toll.
So, how are leaders responding to what's happening,...
...and could we see nations move faster to adjust to climate change?
It’s a tough one.
President Emmanuel Macron is in the southwest today to meet the firefighters...
...who’ve been battling the blazes that have been burning there for more than a week,...
...fire chiefs there today saying for the first time,...
...the lower temperatures and some dropped winds...
...making it easier for them to take more control of the fires.